E
UNITED NATIONS GENERAL ASSEMBLY
IN NEW YORK TONAL.
TONIGHT, WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY TELLS
US THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN DOING
HIS BEST TO TRY TO AVOID SOME
STICKY SUBJECTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT FOR A BIKE
RIDE.
WENT TO CHURCH.
AND WENT TO NEW YORK.
WITHOUT MENTIONING FAILURES IN
AFGHANISTAN, A BOOSTER PROGRAM,
OR THE BORDER.
INSTEAD, STAFFERS ARE ROLLING
OUT NEW COVID-19 POLICIES.
>> IN THE BEGINNING AND EARLY
NOVEMBER, FOREIGN NATIONALS
FLYING TO THE UNITED STATES WILL
BE REQUIRED TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED.
>> THERE'S A BIG LOOPHOLE
THOUGH.
>> IF SOMEBODY WALKS INTO THE
COUNTRY RIGHT ACROSS THE RIVER,
DOES SOMEBODY ASK TO SEE THEIR
VACCINATION CARD?
>> WELL, LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU,
AGAIN, IF THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS,
THEY ARE -- THE INTENTION IS FOR
THEM TO BE QUARANTINED.
THAT IS OUR PROCESS.
THEY ARE NOT INTENDING TO STAY
HERE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF
TIME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THE SAME
THING.
>> STRETCHING FOR MONTHS.
>> ISN'T SHE SUPPOSED TO BE
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND SHE HAS BEEN
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES OF
MIGRATION.
>> THEN THERE IS CHINA FRACTURED
TIES WITH BEIJING ARE SUCH A
THREAT THE U.N. SECRETARY
GENITALS THE A.P. WE NEED TO
AVOID AT ALL COST A COLD WAR
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT FROM THE
PAST ONE AND PROBABLY MORE
DANGEROUS AND MORE DIFFICULT TO
MANAGEMENT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS
RESPONDING.
>> WE WILL MAKE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
THAT HE IS NOT LOOKING TO PURSUE
A FUTURE, A NEW COLD WAR WITH
ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> QUITE A CHANGE SINCE
FEBRUARY.
>> DIPLOMACY IS BACK AT THE
CENTER OF OUR FOREIGN POLICY.
>> THE FOCUS OF FOREIGN POLICY
LATELY THE AFGHAN WITHDRAWAL
WHICH INCLUDED A TERROR ATTACK
THAT KILLED AMERICANS AND U.S.
DRONE STRIKES THAT KILLED
CIVILIANS.
>> THIS WHOLE EXECUTION HAS BEEN
NOTHING BUT A CATASTROPHE.
>> THE PENTAGON IS
INVESTIGATING.
>> WHY WAS THE DECISION TAKEN AS
WE HAVE NOW LEARNED THERE WAS
ANOTHER SURVEILLANCE DRONE
SHOWING THAT THERE WERE KIDS OR
INDIVIDUALS ON THE GROUND?
>> I THINK YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
NOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO REVIEW
THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> NO PLANS TO CHANGE COURSE
THOUGH.
>> YOU GUYS DIDN'T KILL PEOPLE
THAT WENT AFTER OUR TROOPS.
YOU KILLED 10 CIVILIANS
INCLUDING SEVEN CHILDREN.
SO DOES THE PRESIDENT STILL
THINK THESE OVER-THE-HORIZON
STRIKES CAN WORK?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> REFUGEES IN AFGHANISTAN WITH
VISAS ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING OUT.
REFUGEES AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
WITH NO VISAS ARE HAVING NO
TROUBLE GETTING IN.
BUT BEFORE THESE ISSUES VETTING
REFUGEES ARE RESOLVED, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ANNOUNCING
TONIGHT THEY ARE GOING TO DOUBLE
THE NUMBER ALLOWED IN TO THE
U.S. EACH YEAR FROM 62,500 TO
125,000.
BRET?
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, PETER, IT WAS
ALL ABOUT FOLLOW THE SCIENCE AND
THEN THE PRESIDENT HAD THAT
SPEECH ABOUT THE BOOSTER PROGRAM
FOR VACCINES THAT ACTUALLY WAS
SUPPOSED TO START TODAY.
>> YES.
AND GIVEN HIS REMARKS A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, WE COULD HAVE CIRCLED
TODAY ON THE CALENDAR AND
PLANNED AN ON EVENT WHERE THE
PRESIDENT GOES OUT TO A BOOSTER
SHOT CLINIC OR MAYBE EVEN GETS A
BOOSTER SHOT HIMSELF.
BUT THAT DID NOT HAPPEN TODAY
BECAUSE AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE BOOSTERS
WERE GOING TO START TODAY, 16
OUT OF 18 FDA ADVISERS SAID THE
SCIENCE IS NOT THERE.
I ASKED JEN PSAKI ABOUT THIS
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON AND SHE
BASICALLY SAID DON'T FORGET, THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS ALWAYS GOING
TO BE CONTINGENT ON THE FDA AND
ON THE CDC.
SHE ALSO POINTED US TO COMMENTS
FROM DR. FAUCI AND DR. COLLINS
OVER THE WEEKEND THAT IT'S AN
ONGOING PROCESS, BRET.
>> Bret: OKAY, A PROCESS WE WIL